so barack obama went to virginia to get
his old friend terry mcauliffe elected
governor that didn't work well
so he split he fueled up his private jet
he flew to glasgow scotland and while he
was there he immediately started
slinging the cliches our genius
president speaks almost entirely in
cliches which is what dumb people do
that's how you know
here's what he said since we're in the
emerald isles here he said let me quote
the bard william shakespeare
[Laughter]
first of all emerald iowa refers of
course to ireland not to scotland
scotland is not an isle anyway and
shakespeare is the national party of
england not of scotland ask the scots
but whatever more cliches heaped upon
one another
the real point of obama showing up was
to remind everyone that there is a
silver lining they got to hear from him
jesus is here watch
even though i'm not required to attend
summits like this anymore old habits die
hard
and when the issue at hand is the health
of our planet
and the world our children
and our grandchildren will inherit then
you will have a hard time keeping me
away
because when it comes to climate
time
really is running out vote the issue
vote like your life depends on it
because it does
vote democrat or you will die you will
die
maybe republicans ought to try that hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else